oh it's been a while since I've gotten
to wear this so this one is a little bit
impromptu and I'm kind of coming at this
topic sideways I want to kind of take a
look in a revisiting eye to christopher
eccleston 'he's time on Doctor Who and
more specifically his departure from the
show and his reluctance to return so
here's what has been known for some time
he made the decision to leave the show
before the first series was done being
shot and that was not supposed to be
made public until that we in advance of
the party of the ways airing but it got
leaked by the BBC and he had some there
was there's been various sort of
unconfirmed nothing direct from either
him or the producers reports of him
clashing with some of the key figures
involved whether it was Russell T Davies
whether was other producers it's it's
it's not worth speculating on and as a
result
Eccleston has been very sparse on Doctor
Who since his departure he has never
come back to appear on screen again
something which David Tennant did do for
the 50th anniversary which is kind of
the thing that a lot of people hoped he
would come back for including Stephen
Moffat the showrunner at the time
because that was his hope until
Christopher Eccleston turned him down
and he ended up creating the war doctor
instead he does do conventions
intermittently he has yet to appear in
Big Finish
which again is some
thing David Tennant has already taken up
the torch doing and many other people
involved in modern era Doctor Who do a
cast of Torchwood wherefore song you
know lots of stuff being done there he
hasn't shown up for that either and I
kind of want to address that because
some things came out recently that I
think give another perspective on this
cuz I think a lot of us had kind of
assumed largely because Christopher
Eccleston has never said flat out what
the conflict was in detail and neither
has anyone else so everyone's kind of
maintaining a level of professionalism
so we don't know exactly what went down
and it was kind of presumed for a while
that he just held a grudge against the
BBC because there was an agreement for
how his departure was supposed to happen
they didn't stick to it and he was just
ticked at them except he's it took a
while but he did start doing BBC related
things again eventually he's never gone
back to Doctor Who though so it does
seem like it's always seemed like there
was something more unique to the show
that made him reluctant to ever come
back and something that came out
recently which I'm not gonna go so far
as to say is the reason that he hasn't
come back but it has given another layer
to it and that is that at the time he
was anorexic he was battling mental and
physical health issues and he maintains
that his the physical state he was in
again at the time being anorexic was
part of how he was able to secure the
job now whether that's true or not he
certainly seems to believe it and the
reason I kind of want to bring attention
is because again like I know there are
some members of the Doctor Who fan
community who
are annoyed and upset with Eccleston's
very limited engagement with the fandom
and like I have friends very
specifically hold a grudge for his not
coming back to the 50th anniversary and
I feel like it's anyone who feels that
way this is important to take on board
because what this means is his coming
back to the show would be about more
than working with the BBC again it would
be about more than working on the show
again because I at this point anyone who
we might have had his issues with
probably isn't working on the show
anymore but it would be him re-entering
a work environment and a character in a
headspace that he occupied while sick
and that is actually asking a lot of
anybody to do so to make a comparison
anyone who's holding a grudge against
Eccleston for not coming back for
something like the 50th anniversary and
for continuing to engage him with the
fandom fairly sporadically and in
limited ways that would be like being
mad at a recovering alcoholic for not
coming to a party you're having at a bar
it'd be nice if they showed up but if
they decide it's better for their own
health for them not to be there not to
be in that space not to be in that
environment because it might bring back
the pain of past trauma physical and
mental then they're within the right to
say no I can't do that and again I don't
want to overstate this because I am
extrapolating out at least a little bit
because Eccleston has not said flat out
that that is part of why he engages with
Doctor Who as little as
does but I still feel like it's worth
having a full appreciation of because it
becomes a reason where now it makes more
sense than what we had them what we knew
previously on its own as far as why he
doesn't come back why he hasn't gotten
involved with Big Finish why he didn't
come back for the fiftieth anniversary
why he might not come back for any
future big anniversaries we might never
get the Ninth Doctor as portrayed by
Christopher Eccleston in anything
outside of his original 13 episodes and
that would be a shame because he was
fantastic he was really good in that
part
he brought a really unique feel to the
role that other actors happened and
whether you feel that he did better or
worse than anyone else that's a matter
of personal taste but what he brought
was very unique and it's something that
I've always kind of wished we could have
had a little bit more of than we got so
I get the frustration at not having more
but if anybody out there still feels a
frustration against Christopher
Eccleston as a person for that I hope
that you'll find it in your heart to
accept that the guy's got a you've got
to take care of himself that's that's
ultimately kind of the first thing that
every person has to do and I don't mean
like act selfishly but I mean like you
have to you have to take care of your
own body your own mind and if you're not
that needs to be addressed and if you
used to not
then it's a good idea to avoid repeating
that situation or you weren't taking
care of yourself properly so I don't
know I just maybe again maybe it is
because I know people personally who do
kind of or have you know maybe in light
of this they've already softened which
would be amazing but who have
historically kind of held a fairly open
grudge against him for his failure to
ever come back and maybe the people I
know who are like that are a vast
minority I mean I kind of hope so but
just in case just remember the guys yet
yes he's an actor but he's also he's a
human being with stuff to work through
and however he needs to do that let him
do it so yeah there we go
suppose it works that um this is coming
out I'm releasing this the same month as
World Mental Health Day so guess that's
about as close to appropriate as I'll
get with this but in any case whatever
your thoughts are on what I've talked
about or any of this drop something down
in the comments and let's talk about it
there's other stuff to do as well the
like to subscribe both of which are
massively helpful link to the my patreon
even more helpful if you feel like Chuck
in a buck a month my way plus there are
other links down there as well click on
them and they'll take you places but you
also don't have to because I am NOT
gonna tell you what you need to do
you'll decide for yourself what's best
for you and until next time this counsel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]